welcome back to anarcho-capitalism in
practice the third and final attempt the
previous two attempts einvil and vantham
have ended up in feudalism and the
theocratic dictatorship respectively so
it's high time for encaps to finally
score a victory or is it demoralized and
disillusioned a small group of encaps
have decided to flee far away from
bilibov's feudal corporate city and
staffer montreux's absolute staple state
and settled down in a peaceful area down
south founding the settlement of
karlstadt but before they would start
building their society they all came
together in the main square to try and
figure out what went wrong in the
previous two attempts so they can try to
avoid their fate they kept thinking and
thinking and thinking until one end cap
stood up i finally got it he exclaimed
we should lower the age of consent to
12. so they kept thinking and as they
were doing so they also listened to a
quick word from today's sponsor atlas
vpn who is also handing out free
one-year subscriptions to ukrainian
journalists for instructions follow the
link in the description meanwhile the
rest of us get a special discount
meaning 82 of your three-year plan for
199 per month plus one month three with
a 30-day money-back guarantee they offer
a high-speed service suitable both for
streaming and gaming moreover with a
single subscription you'll be able to
protect all your devices at the same
time and not only that atlas also comes
with an ad blocker and malware
protection it blocks all the malicious
links ads and trackers and notifies you
when someone is trying to steal your
data it also helps you get the best
deals while shopping online this
includes online subscription services
such as netflix or spotify also airlines
hotels and more right now atlas vpn is
running a huge discount it means you can
get a 3 year subscription for just 199 a
month with a 30-day money-back guarantee
time is running out so grab the deal by
clicking the link in the description
below with your subscription you will
also have access to atlas's data breach
monitor feature and here's how that
works inside the app you go to bridge
scanner you type in your email and the
app will let you know whether your
personal information had been leaked
through a past or recent breach so make
sure to take advantage of atlas vpn's
huge discount that's a three-year
subscription for just 199 per month with
a 30-day money-back guarantee link in
the description thank you for checking
out atlas vpn heads like this helps
support what i do and now back to the
program
so the end caps kept thinking and in the
end they came up with the following
anarcho-capitalism is at least in theory
anti-monopoly and anti-coercion however
as they realized the accumulation of
wealth instead of being a measure of
success is actually a direct path to a
monopoly which then results in unfair
advantages on the market which then
results in coercion you know if your
company grew is big enough it can use
its disproportionate wealth and
influence to strong arm its competition
out of the market before the latter
would become a threat in all negative
scenarios the common denominator is none
other than currency which desperates can
stockpile thus for monopolies thus exert
coercion they have to get rid of money
but how an n-cap society without money
absurd but then they came up with an
idea they will create a free market
based on service contracts where
everyone's success depends on how many
contracts they can fulfill the contracts
would cover everyone's needs thus
they'll be able to function based on
supply and demand and so the free market
of couchstat was born based on labor and
contracts though it took some getting
used to people eventually got the hang
of service contracts since karostat was
initially just a small village with
maybe 100 inhabitants that had to be
built from scratch most service
contracts pertain to basic work such as
building houses and furniture digging
wells and latrines and of course
producing food payments were also rather
basic in the form of food rations and
very basic communities that could be
produced locally work went rather
quickly however such as building houses
and furniture because most of everyone
took part in them performing subtasks
under the guidance of a person with
construction experience within a short
time frame everyone had shelter and
basic food supply baseline utilities
were also built out such as basic water
and sewage pipes and basic roads since
the residents of culture that were smart
people they realized that these
utilities can produce a so-called
natural monopoly many being refugees
from billy bob's feudalist water
dystopia they knew very well where such
a monopoly can lead they concluded that
in order to have a free and fair market
where everyone starts out with more or
less the same theoretical chances basic
utilities should not be owned by a
single person rather everyone in the
community must be a shareholder as those
utilities are absolutely essential if
anyone wants to do any meaningful
business the same applied to essential
services such as law and order fire
protection and health care the last
thing they wanted was someone to own the
village's only firefighter company and
end up in a situation like romans did
with marcus lenious crassus who
according to wikipedia took advantage of
the fact that rome had no fire
department by creating his own brigade
500 men strong which rushed to burning
buildings at the first try of alarm upon
arriving at the scene however
firefighters did nothing while crassus
offered to buy the burning building from
the distressed property owner at a
miserable price if the owner agreed to
sell the property his men would put out
the fire if the owner refused then they
would simply let the structure burn to
the ground so yes essential services
also had the same ownership structure as
in everyone was a shareholder in them
and everyone had to take part in running
those services if they had the knowledge
or the physical ability so you know you
didn't have to be a professional
firefighter but you could run back and
forth with buckets from a while to a
burning building that sort of thing
housing was also included on the list of
things not to be privatized the
residents of carstad being once again
very smart realized that shelter is a
basic necessity without which a person
cannot meaningfully take part in the
free market they won't be generating
much demand for existing businesses
either being out under the bridge causes
mental and physical illness which
decreases productivity which decreases
income which decreases consumption which
in turn decreases business income thus
the community built basic tournaments
for itself making sure that nobody gets
left out in the cold so the free market
will function well with happy and
healthy consumers the daily work to be
done was announced every morning during
community meetings once every week there
was also a state of affairs meeting
where inhabitants could review their
progress where things are going what are
the lessons learned so far and so on
during one of these meetings the
suggestion arose that colorstat now a
stable settlement with rudimentary
functioning can start expanding its
services namely a professional teacher
for their children and a professional
doctor to permanently run their health
care they put together all the currency
they had left from their previous places
of living and organized an ad campaign
in nearby settlements offering teacher
and doctors jobs in exchange for food
free housing and whatever else they
wanted to get through performing their
service contracts but their little ad
campaign had an unforeseen side effect
since all other settlements operated on
original endcap ideology next to their
wealthy upper classes they also had
sizable underclasses people living
paycheck to paycheck working poor people
sleeping under the bridge and so on and
those people found colorstat's promise
very appealing free shelter a stable
food supply in exchange for work and so
on soon colorstar's population started
growing rapidly however as both people
and service contracts got more and more
numerous it became very difficult to
keep track of everything worse forged
contracts started appearing with
fictitious confirmations of completion
and so on this period came to be known
as the contract chaos after weeks of
pandemonium on the weekly state of
affairs meeting everything threatened to
fall apart the community was on the
brink of collapse when a logistician
whether niko house came up with an idea
she would help create a system that
allows everyone to keep track of and
verify service contracts so there would
always be a master record of who did
what and for whom which anyone can check
this system was of course very risky
since it would put administrators in a
monopoly by having undo control over
resource flows thus to avoid a
traditional and gap scenario they
outlined the tasks and limitations of
such administrators very strictly with
penalties ranging from punishment to
defenestration it's an unintended
benefit this system could also be used
to manage outside trade since it
collects data about everyone's supply
and demand if constant needs materials
from other settlements they could now
trade on more favorable terms by
ordering in bulk instead of each
inhabitant having to individually trade
for the materials needed from the
outside thus began the second phase of
calcstat where residents created a
foreign trade warehouse and the
so-called needs assessment and contract
supervision center the administrators
put an end to the contract chaos and
started effectively organizing service
contracts and with that in the
settlements logistics the administrators
were employed much like teachers and
doctors since they were employed through
the warehouse they also created a
canteen for their food supply to make
life easier for themselves this
warehouse administrator system worked
relatively well in the meantime the
village now a proper town was fully
covered with public utilities this was
facilitated by specialists having direct
and easy access to needed materials
through the warehouse instead of having
to get them individually from different
people from different parts of town this
gave people an idea since it worked so
well with utilities what if everything
was done through the warehouse on their
next meeting they agreed to trade for
computer equipment and hired an i.t
professional who created carlstot's very
own personalized demand and supply
network which sped up administration by
an order of magnitude the warehouse
canteen initially created to serve the
administrators became more and more
popular with the rest of the town
especially now that a cook was working
there full time with the canteen
services people could save a lot of time
since now they didn't have to bother
with cooking as much a food selection
system was integrated into the
personalized demand and supply network
so everyone could put together meals
most suitable for them depending on what
ingredients were available with time
people specialized more and more on
certain tasks these specialists created
workshop cooperatives where all members
were shareholders which allowed them to
share their knowledge and experience
freely since those can't be monopolized
either consequently the quality and
quantity of goods produced increased
significantly to help keep knowledge and
experience freely available to anyone in
the free market they even created a
public library and an open source
knowledge database where anyone could
upload what they wanted pending a public
review after months of struggle to
rebuild their lives the end caps of
colorstat succeeded in reaching what
they would call an ancap utopia or at
least the beginnings of it theirs was a
society free of coercion and oppression
without a government without a
monopolistic ruling class and without
traditional currency also known as
communism
but before any tankies would get too
excited no the soviet union wasn't
communist and it never even came close
to achieving communism it was a state
capitalist oligarchy run by dictators
but that will be the topic of another
video in the meantime thank you for
watching check out my patreon if you
want to support my channel and also
don't forget to like and subscribe and
i'll be seeing you next time